the cocaine mystery at the White House
just keeps getting more complicated as
the story shifts once again officials
now say the illicit drug was found near
the West executive entrance that's
different than the previously reported
West Wing visitor entrance it is a
location that's just steps away from the
highly sensitive Situation Room where
some of the nation's top secret missions
like the raid on Bin Laden take place
House Republicans opening up their own
investigation calling the events
shameful but National Security adviser
Jake Sullivan says there is no need to
worry
situation room is not in use and has not
been in use for months because it is
currently under construction the only
people coming in and going out of the
sit room in this period have been
workers who are getting it ready to go
things got super tense in the briefing
room the White House asked Point Blank
if the cocaine belonged to the Biden
family that question did not go over
well with press secretary Kareem
Jean-Pierre
once and for all whether or not the
cocaine belonged to the Biden family
we're not avoiding the question that is
not true we've answered this question
litigated this question for the last two
days exhaustively the buying family was
not here they were not here
they were at Camp David they were not
here Friday they were not here Saturday
they were not here Sunday they were not
even here Monday they came back on
Tuesday so to ask that question is
actually incredibly irresponsible the
investigation is expected to end next
week but do not expect any arrests
because law enforcement believes that
cocaine culprit is unlikely to be found
since the area is so heavily trafficked
although this is now a less trafficked
area I don't know even the media is
having a hard time believing that
the changing story is raised a little
bit of some eyebrows the fact that it's
close to the situation room is certainly
uh notable normal people just average
people just can't get in there we have
been told political biased Secret
Service folks for days that we may never
know who is the person who left us
behind dropped it it fell out their bag
we threw it away whatever the case may
be
um which you know you talk to folks who
used to work in the White House they
find that a little hard to believe there
are a lot of cameras everywhere in this
white house as you said lots of cameras
in that building hard to believe they
can't track down who it belongs to but
we will see
Charlie they're losing the Press when
you start losing the mainstream media
they're asking questions this is going
to be a headache for them yeah and if
Joe Biden was a press he loses his only
constituency but it is kind of
interesting how how the the baggy the
dime bag is kind of moving its way
through the entire White House from an
area that was you know the library is is
a little bit more secluded uh and uh a
little bit more uh you know exclusive
access to the library but as it as it
sort of moves along and I'm not saying
they're trying to protect anybody I'm
not trying to suggest they're trying to
protect any one individual but I do
think it's kind of interesting that it's
moved its way all the way over to the
West Wing Lobby and then outside of the
situation room and then now they're
talking about oh no but the situation
room is under construction and so you
know it was probably a you know
construction worker well is that the
next step in this conversation I think
it is I think they're doing everything
they can to try to and and again I'm not
would never suggest they're trying to
cover up for anybody
judge how many investigations are there
and this and and this for me as us you
know lawyer types but also as a
journalist the more the position in the
and the story changes the more my intent
go up like why are we not getting the
straight story the first time and now
we're being told we may never know so
just prepare yourself for that okay so
first as Charlie was referencing it's in
the library which is the inner sanctum
the you know and the and the first
family has access to that area then it's
a holiday weekend at a well-traveled
area Korean John Pierre comes out and
she makes the circle bigger all these
people came in it was a holiday weekend
and now it's a situation room which is
now under construction so they had
construction workers as if they don't
have to go through security as if they
don't do drug testing if you're in
construction you do drug testing because
of the kind of equipment you're using
okay so let me just tell you that the
that they they are not answering the one
significant question that America wants
an answer to can you tell us where once
and for all that this did not belong to
the Biden family her outrage you know
betrays her because she her answer is
um we've been clear the Biden family was
not here well I don't know how true that
is because the Biden family was there on
Friday and they found the cocaine on
Friday now as a prosecutor let me uh
that on Sunday they were there they
landed on Sunday but so now I'll put my
prosecutor hat on a cop comes to me and
I he says to me we've got a schedule to
control substance in the White House
most secure house should be in the
country and we want to prosecute it
where's the site of the crime well it's
in the library no maybe it's in the west
wing and one of those cages there no
maybe it was in the situation where my
throw that cap out in a second and if
they were to get a charge defense
attorney would come in and say your
honor this must be dismissed they're
clearly playing with the sight of the
crime and finally let me just say that
when they say we may never figure it out
that means that they don't have an
answer and that even if they had an
answer they don't want to give you an
answer so this is the ultimate cover-up
an illegal substance in one of the most
protected houses in the United States
and their inability and their refusal to
answer questions is an outrage I sense a
bit of skepticism from the judge uh so
let's play a little bit of Jake Sullivan
here talking about the idea that
everybody gets drug tested
we have rigorous drug testing policies
at the White House we have rigorous drug
use policies here at the White House we
take those extremely seriously so we'll
let the investigation unfold if it
involves someone from the White House
the appropriate consequences will ensue
if it involves some visitor who came in
and left it then that's a different
matter
Jessica doesn't it behoove them though
to get a name because they're just
rampant speculation don't you think they
would want to say like we're gonna I
mean he says they'll be punished if we
can figure it out but we're getting
these mixed messages about but we never
may know who it is better for them if we
do know all of us better for everyone
obviously and they know what you say
it's rampant speculation which kind of
implies there could be multiple names
everyone just thinks that Hunter was
blowing lines in the white house right
that's whatever I think everybody thinks
a lot of people speculation I say a good
half the table thinks that right and
the dates I understand green Jean-Pierre
talking about the dates because it does
matter and Kaylee mcinenny who obviously
knows the White House incredibly well
said Hunter's cleared of this he wasn't
there and they do security sweeps so
often that it would have shown up before
that if um it was Hunter who had brought
it in or was even in that specific
location but obviously they need to get
a name and it does just make you think
it should have the most cameras of
basically anywhere in the world right or
one of the top locations very tight
there are very tight visitor logs for
all of us who have been over there and
worked over there you got to get cleared
in nobody just walks in off the street
this is a serious business and this is
an even more inner sanctum kind of area
all right Tyrus you have some thoughts
yeah cocaine's a hell of a drug I've
heard of the Magic Bullet but we have
the magic bag because this thing is
everywhere and nowhere at the same time
it's it's magical
um listen they told the story okay so
let me just break it down for you
somebody who can go around the White
House
likes to have a little candy
and knew a room that was under
construction
take somebody in that room to hang out
have some fun do some stuff because it's
construction nobody will know my dad
runs the place we can hang out here all
we want to okay that sounds like shake
your head wait till your kids get older
okay hypothetically hypothetically I'm
just speculating here I thought this was
a round table Yeah thoughts and ideas I
don't know it's true it's not true but
here's the deal if it wasn't theirs
they'd be like there's no way this could
be this and there's no way this could be
that when they say things like purview
47 times in the wrong context every time
when they say well it was here and it
wasn't there could have been anyone I
guess we'll never know that stuff my
kids say to me with chocolate chip
cookies all over their face and a broken
jar behind them going who broke the jar
we might not ever know Dad
okay I'm gonna tell you what happened
that's the only thing that she's not
saying is this what happened okay I'm
gonna tell you what happened there was a
bag and it blew in through the window
okay and it like landed in the library
and then
maybe a ghost
brought it into this other room they
know exactly who did it where he did it
and why he did it and that's why they're
like I don't know because some genius in
there seems to say no the American
people will never put this together
every parent any person who's ever
bought a dime bag or anything like that
knows exactly who took their stash they
know exactly how it happened you guys
are using the lingo yeah I know the
lingo I've never I've never done it not
judging my favorite basketball player of
all time was Lenny bias he was drafted
by the Boston Celtics I was I remember
where I was in the day yep I came home
sat down on my steps and cried because
he died of a cocaine and I've never
touched it ever because I just thought
if it killed him once it could do it to
me hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else